I have a question about histamine. I'm looking at your list of high histamine level foods
and I'm well confused. The sample says high histamine foods are beans and pulses and it says
chickpeas or maybe peanuts are those the only beans that should that are high histamine or are you
saying that all beans are high? I've been watching that for a long time. Well, I put it on
pause. Oops. I'm going to mute everybody here again because we're going to feed back. Okay,
so remember with histamines, make sure you go back and watch some of the videos on histamines
because it'll help you because it gets confusing with histamines. Most foods have histamined it.
So it's you're never going to be able to hide from histamines completely. Almost all foods,
the older they are, have more histamines. So leftover foods have more histamines than
fresher foods. So you're going to make a big dinner and eat it all week long because it's going
to be leftovers in the fridge. By the time the third day comes, it's got a lot more histamines
in the first day and there's different studies that have measured that and sometimes it could
triple quadruple over time. So you're not the idea is that you're not you're not
expelling histamines from your diet. You are trying to decrease your histamine load. So if a person
has defects especially in the ABP1 genes that break down histamine in the gut by secreting the
DAO enzyme, that means defects in that gene. I don't have a lot of histamine breakdown enzyme
in my gut. Then you want to decrease your histamine consumption. So decreasing your histamine
consumption is then just looking at that chart of high histamine foods. Staying away from I think on
that chart, I think they're in red or they in light, I can't remember that chart.
And then the ones that are in bold are the ones that have the things that have the least about a
histamine in it. But there is a steady way that you're going to get rid of all histamines. So just
try to stay away. All beans have histamine. All nuts have histamine in them. So should I never eat
beans anymore, should I ever eat nuts anymore. No, but maybe if I have issues with histamine,
I'm not going to eat a handful of nuts. I can still have some nuts on my salad. The more foods you
mix them in with, you're going to have less of a histamine load in your gut at any given time.
Or if I know I'm going to eat something that's very high histamine, then I could take a histamine
enzyme with that that that ABP would assist product that we have or the histo DAO product that's
the straight histamine enzyme. That's how you want to look at histamine. You want to look at it as a
bucket that you are going to fill, but you don't want that bucket tippy to over. That's all.
Okay, thank you. That's helpful. And I'll watch the video too. That would be interesting.
Thank you. Oh, you bet. That's a freezing food help.
No, histamine is a debito acid, so it doesn't die. It's not a libido-organic acid.
So freezing doesn't, like I said, you stored it for a week and it increases in histamine.
Well, yeah, if you freeze it, it probably won't increase in histamine. Okay, thank you.